well you know the long summer break from
school can sometimes lead to setbacks
for young students so this summer there
are some learning opportunities to help
those kids stay on track and our Candace
Charles is live at the CCSD headquarters
near Sahara and Decatur hey Candace
hey you guys good morning to you good
morning folks good thing is these
learning opportunities are free CCSD has
summer acceleration and distance
learning at the Nevada Department of
Education is investing in a summer
learning program aimed at teaching
children entering the kindergarten into
second grade in the fall now ccnc is
doing federal funds to continue its
acceleration extended school year and
secondary summer school programming it's
also offering a distance learning option
at Nevada Learning Academy now they've
seen an increase in enrollment since the
pandemic and tell me they hope this will
continue to help students who may have
experienced learning loss of the valley
Department of Education has partnered
with waterford.org to provide the
Waterford upstart summer learning path
to help break barriers to accessing
Early Education all intended to help
students get on track and stay on track
class sizes may be smaller there may be
opportunities for students to have more
Independent Learning with their teachers
and say they are struggling still with
literacy and say they're at that
critical age where they need to learn
how to read for understanding they can
have those opportunities
but that certainly does help now the
summer acceleration program runs from
May 30th to June 16th all you have to do
is go to your child's school to sign up
I have the dates as well as how to sign
up for the divided by Department of
education's opportunity also on our
website 8newsnow.com for now live from
the Clark County admin building I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now